on this episode we talk charisma the
lonely road of success and hashtags
[Music]
[Music]
Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 159 of the askgaryvee
show
Monday morning nice and cool 7:30
teacher conference from Missha this
morning which was fun oh he's good to
hear that your child is amazing and
first grade there's only so much damage
one kid I mean even I was a great
student in first grade in a good mood
the jet squeaked it out there's one
point before to give him a late
touchdown that the score was very close
to my prediction which I was happy with
but very concerned about Thursday's game
do we have a I don't go to Orlando
Wednesday do we have a show tomorrow and
oh do we will in Thursday morning okay
great you'll get it out before the game
perfect so I'll make my official
prediction Thursday you'll probably get
in the afternoon early afternoon right
before the game plenty time for all you
gamblers to put in your but I'll give
you an early indication I'm very
concerned any time you play a team that
hasn't won 12 games in a row on the road
like the Jags hadn't and you win the
turnover battle for 2-0 and you only win
by five points there's a lot of stuff
going on there's a lot of injuries that
Jets are banged up so that's that had a
good apologizer I actually was super sad
missed the entire week last year last
year last week is probably one of only
two times or three times since we
started to show where I missed an entire
week
so that's stunk sorry about that but I'm
glad to be back in the saddle Indy it's
good to see you good to see that you've
stayed consistent with your black attire
oh my god that's a big deal that's very
short for you wow what happened there I
was how much it got cut off I could use
some of that alright India let's get
into the awesome also a little new thing
that I started doing what I just emailed
you guys randomly on this right
random vaynermedia employee to just join
every time oh by the way yeah there you
go good job why don't you tell the
vaynernation real quick who you are and
then we'll get him to show what you do
here have a nation where did you grow up
Jersey Shore and what football team do
you love New York yeah yeah nothing
random about that actually was you
picked that yeah good job India your
city your and you watch the Jets just
for a little bit Oh India you had
momentum going but the Niners played
lead you guys played early no no but the
Jets were early the Niners were late
what are you like I'm just like sleep in
Miss the wake up at like 4:00 were you
waving to 4:00 in the morning in Queens
yeah let's get in the show enough banter
for a Monday salty snaps ask people say
the road to success is lonely do you
feel that's accurate if not why do you
think it's a common sentiment you know I
think people use that that a statement
because the truth is I mean first of all
it depends on how you just find success
in the context of what way this show is
about which is business success
obviously we talk about a lot of life
stuff as well but you know when you're
the CEO when you were the founder the
conversation that's not being had
everybody sees all the nice things that
come along but like you know every
single thing that happens in this
company that's wrong is my fault
every snarky comment on social every
kind of like sad face every email bullet
points that I every Friday I get bullet
points from tons of vaynermedia
employees and and 80% of them have a
bullet that's like Rick is stretched too
thin and is crying in the bathroom
that's devastating it's very tough to be
at the top of something even when it's
going great
Vader is going great this is not even
like you know Wall Street collapse and
we lost a lot of clients so we have to
have layoffs like this is like we're
rolling and we're the best and we're
crushing and there's always things to
worry about because you know that
there's
oh there's no oh it's India's fault
everybody here at some level all the way
up can still say if Gary's fault I can't
and when you say it's my fault there's a
really tough burden emotionally forget
about financially that comes along with
that and so I think it can get very
lonely you do recognize it's amazing to
me for as much of a community and
extrovert as I am how much I keep in my
own mind how much is going on in this
noggin every day calculating
strategizing thinking and there is no
vacations I desperately love national
holidays and like I can't wait for
Christmas and Thanksgiving because
everybody else is checked out and that's
the only time that's the only time that
I'm able to be off I have my 40th
birthday coming on Saturday I'm going
away with my family this is an
incredible moment in my life and I will
not be able to be 100% checked out
because then those you know in that
Friday and that Monday the world is
moving this world is moving my
responsibilities are moving and I'm
always one phone call away from a fire
that I have to address it is a very
intense lonely place to be at the
tippy-top and so when you think about
you know I always think about like is
life fair right there's always things
that happen
there's things that we can't control but
the notion of like you know somebody
getting compensated a lot of money for
things that we do I think somebody
making 20 million dollars a year to be
an athlete or an actress we never talk
about actresses and actors right we love
to sing on athletes but like actors make
like the big ones make like 815 million
dollars to make a movie but still at the
end of day it's because they command the
market people want to pay attention and
there's an enormous amount of pressure
as I've lived my life and started
spending some time with a list
celebrities their life is it means
intense like I really secretly think
that I could be an a-list celebrity that
I literally could go on TV and be a
breakout hit like in a Mad Money kind of
like you know kind of not like a not
like Jennifer Lawrence I just don't have
the looks but in a Mad Money kind of
like Regis kind of like Andy Cohen way
but man real celebrity status is intense
you just have nowhere to go and so
there's that or
an athlete we're like the physical shape
that you have to 18 you know 10 hours a
day of putting in that time people look
at the outcomes they don't think about
what's coming along with it and the
pressure the pressure to know that if I
get hit wrong that my entire life
collapse especially an athlete that's
short window or the pressures that we
look I don't think it's a coincidence
that some of the greatest artists of all
time pass away in their mid-20s because
of the intensity it's intense its
intense it's very lonely and so it could
be extremely lonely I ironically a new
find this wild I love it look I don't
want random extra people in the room
like like so like I love being around
people more than anything but I'm also
very comfortable in my own being
one on one with myself so I'm good but
but I know that I'm emotionally stable
as [ __ ] and it's intense for me I can't
imagine people that are not as fortunate
as I am pulling from both directions
ambition but humility you know you know
like you don't content I am like a lot
of people watch a show and you hear I
want to buy the Jets and and you
misunderstand really where I'm at like I
want it all and I want to win the whole
thing but if I'd never win again if I
plateau at this level there's an amazing
amount of content in my body for all my
hunger and and and that balances me but
I couldn't imagine if that was tweak
just a little bit if I really felt the
pressure because there's enough pressure
from a day-in and day-out standpoint
it's intense its intense
I think people say it I think much like
stereotypes or statements there's always
so many truth to it I think the reason
so many people say the road is lonely
because to really be successful in the
context of business especially you've
got to make seven to seven thousand
decisions that are critical and you can
only make them with yourself and it's an
intense moment on a daily basis yeah a
little bit of a rant to start Monday
morning let's go a little lighter there
India Kyle Kyle ass you think Travis
kalanick and onine before we knew who he
was who is someone we don't know today
but will in the future
well I were to comment think I would
good to know
wasn't really asking about how they were
dissing you or they enjoying the content
okay yes
how this guy's asked this question at
that I was you really made him sweat
this one out India I saw this question
on social a lot yeah yeah I thought
anyway go ahead
the reason who asked that Kyle the
reason I didn't send India this question
and say hey you need to ask this because
I saw you pounding it over and over so
great perseverance way to get on the
show
is because I don't think I have an
answer to that there is one entrepreneur
guy by name abend Sarah who created face
feed who's doing some consulting now on
the west coast who I think is magical
CER a and there's an amazing amount of
people that I think are real winners
just tons but nobody that makes me feel
like they'd been Sara's the only one
that makes me feel like he's got a
trillion dollar execution in him so
that's the answer and it's a truth is
it's still early intuition I'm been Sara
compared to with Travis I just knew
which only speaks to the uber miss on
the angel round multiple times even more
baffle it's really the great mystery of
my life fall in Alaska Gary to what
extent would you say it successes
studious showmanship slask charisma
factor thanks angel I think my
showmanship and charisma is a major
factor my charisma is an absolute being
charming is is a stunningly important
personal trait like being likable is
really cool and I especially have a
weird thing going on because in my
public persona especially when I'm on
stage or performing I get very
competitive very like I want a rap
battle the world right like I want to
beat everybody
so I'm combative and I say things that
most people don't want to say so it
makes a certain group uncomfortable and
actually makes them not like me as much
and so then when they meet me one-on-one
and that charming kind of real person
plays out I even get extra credit you
know listen I think it's a major factor
now on the flip side I can rattle off 50
people which I won't because this is a
diss that are massively charming
massively charismatic but have no depth
it's classic sizzle and steak I think I
have both now do I think a steak that
really sizzles sells better it sure does
and so I would almost say me if it's 50%
if you want to go basic it's 50% of my
success because having the goods to back
up that hyperbole and charisma and
excitement and showmanship is a major
thing like there's a lot of people
faking this show there's a lot of
content on YouTube and out there there's
a lot of people that are trying like
there's a lot of people doing a quote
pictures the way I do them or videos the
way I'm not talking about you d-roc and
and and doing videos the way I do
and there isn't traction because I think
people can smell it and so you have to
be able to back it up and so butBut I
don't run away from it I I definitely
think that I hate when people don't
think that they're lucky like I don't
know how to not quantify my charisma my
personality as anything short of I took
great features from my parents who dis
you know my parents deciding to get
married unfortunately even though my dad
ever watches the show which he doesn't
mom make sure you show Dad this part as
much as I'd love to take credit for mom
and dad getting married I just can't
my dad always like citizen me for taking
credit for stuff so yeah I think I think
my personality is a major factor I'm
also equally happy to know that my work
ethic and my tenacity and my skills and
my compassion are equally fact there's
my success I think my mom's watching
almost everyone yeah
around ram g'day Gary Ram Costello here
from giant thinkers dot-com recording is
from Sydney Australia I am an author
blogger podcaster speaker and creative
live instructor that helps emerging
designers be employed I have a what
would you do question Gary currently I
have one book and creative life courses
for all of us bloggers and podcasters
out there that are looking to better
monetize what would your next right hook
be would it be to create another book
potentially a video course or even a
membership component Cheers
let's have a question Ram right Ram
great question big shout out to
Australia it looks like Australia next
March for the book tour is becoming very
realistic so going down under can be fun
haven't been there since I've been in
the wine world not true actually just
remembered I flew in and flew out for a
business talk three or four years ago um
Graham I think it comes down to what's
the best product you could put out it
whatever form you think that you can
execute in whether that's a second book
because you're a great writer or an
online course cuz you're charismatic on
video or a membership site because you
think you can provide enough value worth
paying for that's differentiated market
and yes you can taste my cynicism there
or continuing to build up your brand to
become more of a persona that gets to
publicly speak I think speaking is a
very lucrative way to monetize someone's
personality I think it'd be really
interesting if since it sounds like
you're teaching other people to become
employed I think it'd be really
interesting for you to do more of that
yourself so instead of teaching people
how to make money maybe you go out and
get employed more so that you can speak
to like I did a million dollars worth of
gigs this year I think you know that for
me I'm cynical to people just teaching
for a sake of teaching so I enjoy the
fact that I I've built a love course
with a Ginty but like I built a machine
that does you know seem to be a hundred
million dollars in social media work it
sure gives me a lot of oomph to sit on
like this stuff works cuz these
companies don't keep us around because
I'm carriers
and so you like up you like the recall
there recall go ahead see fun Stefan hey
Stefan hasty pond over there talk to
Stefan and I'll take a recall component
here a little rusty week away and that
so I think all those are our viable
options said for everybody's watching
you can tell the the back end ones were
the ones I'm more excited about because
I love proof in the pudding
I love proof in the pudding I love proof
in the pudding let me do you think of
Bill Cosby too is he that associated
with pudding for me it is he's an
interesting spot these days what's that
oh the porridge pop up we have to pop we
have to punt that right because like
people expect us to do it now and I
don't think Steve can pull it off I mean
I haven't heard from him in a week Kylie
Kylie ass you never use hashtags what's
the hell that's a really good point
Kylie I saw that question who comes
through social and I wanted I mean I
dodge that like as quickly as I could
that's a shortcoming I'm not doing a
good job I'm really screwing up
Instagram especially I'm not happy with
myself this is a lazy ver and I never
talked of myself and lazy I'm doing a
porch as a matter of fact I'm gonna fix
this team we need to get our [ __ ]
together I need you to help me here can
we get like seven to ten hat we did this
once and I didn't execute on it this is
the second time around we need I need to
understand better what hashtags I need
to be using on Instagram I just have
time to put in for the homework find the
white space not the ones not
entrepreneur because that is a lot like
what's the longtail version Kylie a
great question India great job I'm
asking the question this is a
shortcoming you know I like any other
human go through the ebbs and flows of
not doing things well as a matter fact I
don't think I handle my personal brand
all that well up until the askgaryvee
show because I was so busy executing
this one is even worse because I'm
actually doing it there's no reason I
shouldn't be adding four to seven
strategic at Stags per post for
discovery of new people I just need to
get better it's a lack of practition or
execution one that one that angers me
that we had address it and maybe even
ruin my week
now that this has been exposed listen
it's a great question and and this is
one of the few times and this hurts my
feelings but this is one a few times I
need to say
don't look at my behavior do it the
right way you need to be using it it's a
it's a free discovery tool in these
channels and I think I think I'm mailing
it in specifically on Instagram so what
the hell is I'm dropping the ball and
that uh that hurts that's right I won't
call it sad anymore I'm now motivated
it's a motivating note thank you guys
for watching the show that I feel like
there's something I want to say but the
Iraqis anything we want to say they have
no films in the making oh we have a
speaking trailer coming out but that's
kind of it all right yeah we have two we
have two films how close one more our
next film be out in next month because
you're hedging my time Jeff all right
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]
[Music]